oh my gosh
okay
so good afternoon
i'm very pleased and happy to welcome
here president
maya sandu
a very warm welcome again here in the
berlin we had in during the last weeks
and month intensive talks several
meetings phone calls in particular about
the glass gas supply crisis in moldova
i have announced an emergency package to
step up our support to moldova and i'm
very glad that today commissioner vahley
and the foreign minister for moldova
will both sign the package
um we are providing 60 million euro to
reduce the impact of the rising gas
prices on the most vulnerable people in
moldova
i am of course also looking very much
forward to our discussions which we will
have this afternoon at the eastern
partnership summit
and there we will not only address these
topics but also of course other topics
like how to fight the pandemics but also
the tension in the neighborhood and our
investment economic and investment plan
for the region
of the eastern partnership so very warm
welcome dear maya good to have you here
thank you very much
thank you madam president of the
european commission
the
ceremony is again proof to the
fact that eastern partnership has been
successful to moldova
and i would like to take this
opportunity to thank you again and to
thank you the institutions of the eu for
the support that they've been providing
to us
during goods and during bad times the eu
support is very important for our
development agenda
the eu support comes as solidarity help
when we badly need it and the energy
crisis is such an example
and the the
resources the support that we're
receiving today is going to go
for the
vulnerable people for the people with
low incomes
but we're also looking forward to
continue to work with you and with your
team to provide for energy security for
the country so that will not
have to face crisis situations like this
in the future thank you very much again
and very happy to see here to to be here
today and to witness this important
ceremony all right let's put on our
masks again
and
let's move on to our
excellencies ladies and gentlemen we
will now witness the signature of the
state and resilience building contract
for the republic of moldova
deputy prime minister and minister of
foreign affairs nico popeshko will sign
for the republic of moldova
commissioner for neighborhood and
enlargement olivier vareli will sign for
the european commission and the
signature will be witnessed by her
excellency maya sandhu president of the
republic of moldova and her excellency
ursula van der lion president of the
european commission you may now proceed
for the signature
[Applause]
uh
thank you very much
you